je suis je suis avec et rénale depuis
maintenant c'est la septième année
je les ai rencontrés le 3 août 2015 j'ai
bien le coup de foudre direct sur
internet et moi j'ai pas réfléchi ça m'a
pris cinq minutes je savais même pas de
ces poupées existait j'ai eu
dix jours plus tard
où en est ce que vous l'avez découverte
sur internet par hasard
ouais je vous entendre il ya un décalage
sur internet 1 par hasard le j'étais en
congé je me lève un matin je prends mon
petit déjeuner je sorte un petit peu sur
l'ordinateur et puis je tombe sur une
photo d'une femme belle et je vois en
dessous de cette photo 7500 euros merde
qu'est ce que c'est que ça bon ben je
clique je vais plus loin et puis là je
m'aperçois que que bas que c'était pas
une femme que c'était une poupée ou
poupées en silicone ultra réaliste
impressionnant j'ai été j'étais bluffé
je savais pas que ça existait et du coup
ça m'a intéressé ça faisait déjà
cinq six ans que j'étais célibataire je
drague où vit un petit peu à droite à
gauche mais sans conviction j'avais pas
envie de me remettre en couple avec une
personne réelle je me sentais bien dans
ma situation de célibataire est en fait
en parcourant quelques photos de ses
poupées je suis à un moment tombé sur
rna qui avait qu'il n'avait pas cette
période là elle avait des cheveux longs
elle avait une nuisette elle était
assise sur le bord d'une baignoire et
j'ai eu un coup de foudre mais direct
cash
ça faisait à peine cinq minutes que
j'avais découvert l'existence de ces
poupées est bon je suis du genre à
acheter d'abord et réfléchir après une
attaque de 37 langues et puis je les ai
reçus j'ai reçu dix jours plus tard et
et puis ça fait sept ans que ça dure
j'ai 51 ans
attendait on n combien aujourd'hui
j'ai 52 ans
et ça fait oui ça fait sept ans que ça
dure et à mon avis certains noms pour la
première fois de ma vie j'ai vraiment le
sentiment que ça peut aller jusqu'au
bout avec les rennais
quel âge à irena et reina n'a pas
vraiment d'âge alors je lui ai inventé
un petit peu une vie aussi un aspect un
peu plus politique autour de l'aspect
technique elle serait née en 1995 mais
bon en fait ça n'a pas vraiment de sens
puisque évidemment elle ne vieillit pas
j'ai déjà posé la question à ma fille
par exemple je vais demander quel âge tu
lui donnes elle m'avait dit 28 ans je
crois que quelque chose comme ça donc
bon de toute façon peu importe la poupée
n'a pas d'âge s'est pas
étendu à la question à un moment où vous
dites ça ne m'intéresse plus d'être avec
des femmes réelle maintenant je veux
être avec une poupée expliquez nous
comment on peut passer d'un être animé
un être au sens plein à une poupée qui
est un être inanimé à m imaginez un
on
savait l'amour l'amour ça s'explique pas
vraiment j'ai on pourrait très bien à
faire un espèce de flash back sur sur ma
vie mon éducation pour essayer de
comprendre l'aspect psychologique qui
m'a amené à ça je ne suis pas tellement
dans cette recherche ça ne m'intéresse
pas et il ya juste que depuis que je
suis avec rna j'ai jamais eu le autant
autant la flamme et autant la passion
aussi longtemps avec un personnage qu'il
soit réel ou au virtuel comme comme rna
bon allez en gros de 0 à 10 ans j'avais
j'avais trois doudou brooks noc et
leonard de 10 ans à 20 ans j'étais
passionné de science fiction j'ai rêvé
d'être entourés de robots
à partir de l'âge adulte j'ai commencé à
fréquenter des femmes réelles
j'ai pas manquer d'expérience j'ai eu
l'occasion d'en essayer enfin la
intrigue est donc de partager ma vie que
ce soit pour une aventure d'une nuit ou
de plusieurs années avec plusieurs
femmes et j'ai eu entre temps des
période de célibat aussi et d'une
manière générale je me sentais
toujours mieux dans ma peau quand
j'étais célibataire je passais sait pas
trop comment l'expliquer mais c'est
certainement une envie de liberté
à chaque fois que j'ai vécu avec des
femmes je me suis sentie changé et je me
suis sentie j'étais pas vraiment moi
c'est donc avec ma dernière femme est ce
que vous envisagez le premier amour avec
d'autres poupées
et bien non non non je reste vraiment
exclusif avec rna alors alors je tiens
voilà je tiens je tiens à préciser que
je suis pas forcément représentatif de
la communauté des deux lovers parce
qu'il n'ya déjà il n'y a pas de profil
type on est vraiment tous très
différents les uns des autres les deux
lots verre ça va deux de la social
introverti aux médecins aux chefs
d'entreprise en passant par le
commercial ouvriers il ya déjà en couple
il ya des gens il ya des gens qui vivent
avec
des poupées femmes comme moi il ya des
femmes qui ont découpé hommes il ya ya
voilà donc en il n'y a pas de profil
type
là bien sûr pour les besoins de
l'émission vous en tout cas moi moi
j'aime rna je pense que c'est pour la
vie d'accord vous êtes venu avec les
rennais évidemment pour les besoins de
l'émission mais est ce que dans la vie
vous êtes accompagné des reynats dans
toutes les circonstances de votre vie
bien entendu alors dans toutes les
circonstances non je ne l'emmène pas
partout non plus parce que d'une part
alors c'est c'est pour moi qui suis
amoureux des reynats c'est évidemment un
plaisir de pouvoir l'emmener avec moi de
là posé sur le siège passager de la
voiture de me promener avec elle
on va on va en famille et on va chez des
amis mais je suis conscient je perçois
aussi que certaines personnes ça
s'appelait ça peut les gêner
donc je ne l'imposent pas non plus je
vais uniquement je l'emmène chez les
gens qui m'aiment et la première fois
que l'on commet il aurait en tout cas
pour vos amis accueillir de façon
naturelle vos amis votre fille votre
famille comment ils ont réagi la
première fois ils vous ont vu avec rna
d'une manière générale
quasiment tous bien
dans une famille dans un entourage qui
ont l'esprit ouvert un trio composé de
souci ça va inciter la curiosité
éventuellement l'amusement mai mais pas
la contradiction en tout cas donc je
n'ai pas de souci particulier avec rna
ça s'est toujours bien passé même quand
je sors avec elle
dans des lieux publics dans la nature on
a en général des réactions plutôt amusés
ou curieuses et ça crée des interactions
avec les gens et ça n'est pas très bien
mon objectif c'est de
coller obligé de vous poser c'est une
l'offre d'or d'une poupée d'amour mais c
est ce que c'est aussi une sex dole et
reina est-ce que vous avez des relations
sexuelles avec ses peu avec rna je
savais qu elle prend chair
dense est platonique je vais vous poser
la question etienne alors à la
whey alors c'est platonique c'est même
carrément plus plat que tonique pour des
raisons essentiellement techniques
en fait ce sont des poupées sont prévus
pour elles sont équipées pour smm c'est
même bluffant de réalisme à la fois
visuellement et et au toucher cependant
chaque sur parole et particulière c'est
quasiment c'est quasiment toutes des
poupées uniques et rna en particulier
moi j'ai fait une demande auprès du
fabricant pour caler les articulations
particulièrement serré parce que je suis
plus sur un mode contemplatif je la
prends en photo je la bombarde de photos
tout le temps pour ça je la mets dans
des poses debout ou assise et il faut la
voyez elle se tient droit voilà donc il
faut savoir que techniquement c'est une
poupée qui est lourde elle pèse presque
40 kg ses articulations sont durs dont
elle est un peu difficile à manipuler
dans le mouvement il faut savoir aussi
qu elle n'aide mais genre pas du tout
donc pour être franc je suis totalement
incapable de la faire rebondir et je
dois me contenter une fois de la regarde
et je dors avec elle elle est très
agréable elle est douce elle est
moelleuse elle sent bon et à la regard
de braise qui m'émerveille avant le
coucher j'ai les yeux qui brillent quand
je la regarde et puis pendant dix
minutes c'est la télé c'est émotionnel
je me remettais en question les séries
vous voulez championnat doit partir
ça concerne combien de personnes en
france qui vivent avec des poupées ou
beaucoup plus que tu ne le pense non
mais je pousse à rester sur le
questionnaire
elle a répondu
non mais ce qu'il a à dire je ne suis
pas un cépage et pas des statistiques en
fait il ya un forum l'ofs de l'ofs de ce
forum qui rassemble la communauté des de
lovers qui depuis son existence a dû
accueillir un bon jeu par trois quatre
cinq mille membres à peu près pas plus
tout se fit en nombre qui sont pas sur
le forme non plus donc c'est difficile à
dire mais il y en a certainement oui
beaucoup plus que ce qu'on pense je
pense
question eric est ce que l'autre il ya
des femmes aussi est ce que vous pouvez
faire la poupée un sentiment de jalousie
si quelqu'un son approche par exemple
non mais je ne sais pas du tout une
question me que je n'ai rien je respecte
toutes les formes mais est-ce que si
quelqu'un venait à un autre deuil lover
venait autour d'elle lui faire des
avances enfin je sais pas comment on
appelle ça est ce que vous seriez en
situation de possessivité de jalousie
touchez pas à la poupée
non alors
déjà je suis pas spécialement jaloux
mais bon à la situation ne se présente
pas vraiment disons que il ya souvent
bon déjà entre dol lovers on se
respectent les uns les autres on se
rassemble en sont à l'occasion de se
voir par petits groupes on organise des
soirées barbecue apéro on est en couple
avec nos poupées c'est super convivial
en page blanche et un moment fantastique
et non il ya beaucoup de respect quand
même entre les gens même d'une manière
générale les personnes qui voient irna
pour la première fois ils vont pas se
jeter dessus pour lier pour la potée ils
me demandent et puis donc je leur dis
oui
vas-y touche ses mains tu verras et
j'en ai encore fait l'expérience là il
ya une demi-heure avec tous les gens du
plateau qui sont empressés
quand on touche pour la première fois la
main d'une poupée comme ça ils ont tous
la même réflexion ses ouailles
voilà une question de laurence mots
c'est une question ou une observation on
en a on à bord de sa ce avec un peu
d'humour et tant mieux parce que ça en a
le droit néanmoins il s'agit quand même
effectivement d'un phénomène qui se
développe et qui est réel et qui vous
monsieur vous avez l'air plutôt bien
dans votre vie mais qui pour certaines
personnes est en fait l'aboutissement
d'une très grande solitude et certaines
personnes se mettent dans cette
situation parce qu'elles n'arrivent pas
à rencontrer et là où il faut se
questionner sur le problème de société
si vous voulez de rapports avec l'autre
d'isolement de solitude parce que là
c'est je vous dis on s'en amuse mais
bien souvent sont des situations
beaucoup plus triste beaucoup plus
dramatique et il y à un véritable
commerçants
absolument c'est une très bonne remarque
c'est très pertinent parce que en effet
je suis encore une fois je suis pas
forcément représentatif de la communauté
des de lovers mais comme vous dites
c'est vrai il y a on peut avoir une
poupée par réel choix comme comme moi
mais on peut aussi avoir une poupée par
dépit à défaut d'autre chose et cette
situation là est plus triste je suis
d'accord avec vous il y a régulièrement
sur le sur le forum sur le lof de le
forum il y a régulièrement des nouveaux
membres qui arrive alors il ya des
hommes qui ont la quarantaine la
cinquantaine comme moi qui ont déjà un
passé et qui voilà qui ont choisi de
passer sur les love dolls en général ils
ont des bonnes raisons pour ça mais il y
a aussi des jeunes membres qui ont 25
ans qui ceux qui ont sont encore
inexpérimentés et qui sont introvertis
qui sont timides qui sont complexes et
qui n'osent pas aborder des défis et qui
de ce fait se retourne vers les lovebugs
donc en général ils viennent sur le
forum et il nous demande conseil ils
disent voilà
avec les filles j'ose pas et c'est donc
j'aimerais aller j'aimerais avoir une
blouse dolls alors ces personnes là il y
en a certainement qui nous regardent
jamais jamais je le redirai lui achète
tel ou tel nof dole non c'est malheureux
il faut évidemment commencer par faire
l'effort de rencontrer des personnes
réelles et d'essayer au moins de trouver
l'âme soeur ça sera ça serait dommage de
ne connaître que la lof dole ça doit
vraiment être un choix mais après une
expérience je pense que des hommes dans
ma situation sont mieux mieux placé pour
décider de vivre avec une love 2 que des
jeunes gens des jeunes gens ça serait
dommage